all right before we get started with
today's video i want to thank the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by aspire because
star wars republic commando is out for
the nintendo switch in playstation 4.
it's 14.99 you want to click the link
below check it out this game really does
a good job at making you feel like you
are a republic commando of a group of
clone troopers it's a first person
shooter that also has
tactical elements in there so i love
that i'm glad it's here for a whole new
generation
or the whole generation playing it again
for that nostalgia factor or platinum
trophy farming on ps4 there is a plot
for this game and i promise you if you
played this game back in the day
you already did more than enough to get
what would have been the platinum trophy
if trophies existed back then but they
didn't but the point is just
do now what you did then you'll get the
platinum probably these trophies always
underestimate us
old-school gamers when we played for the
joy and fun of it and it is one of those
games that even in the height of my
prequel hating days i was like
yeah but some of these games are awesome
that's just legit it is a game that has
its place among the great memories of
fun star wars gaming so again click the
link below check it out it's 14.99 for
nintendo switch and playstation 4. and
thank you once again to aspire for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now falcon
on the winter soldier
and zemo because who are we kidding wow
a lot happened in this episode first of
all spoiler alert for this episode of
falcon and the winter soldier as always
and as always i usually say like
this isn't a play-by-play i can't
mention everything this episode in
particular if i miss something that you
loved
don't hate not too harshly anyway but
right when this episode started out
starts out six years ago bucky's in
wakanda
and he's basically being tested to see
if that programming
has now been dealt with she's reading
off the list of words you know the
butcher the baker the candlestick maker
all that and sebastian stan just
fighting it
gritting his teeth tears coming out of
his eyes
dude that's what i'm here for that's
what i'm saying this show gets to show
a little more also love the swell of the
winter soldier theme and the imagery is
flashing and he's fighting it
i love this show's use of music because
i could have sworn i haven't rewatched
it but when bucky was throwing down and
he was pretending to be the winner
soldier
for zemo i swore i heard the winter
soldier theme creeping up in there
also when john walker was sitting there
looking like he was about to cry in that
scott farkas from christmas story kind
of way i'm not the biggest kid on the
playground the song that was playing
right there was a slowed down version of
captain america civil war
i thought that was awesome good use of
music in this show thus far but yeah as
we thought wakanda's like
nah we want zemo we'll give you eight
hours because we got history
but eight hours bucky's like [ __ ] all
right long story short they're going
after carly and sam
actually has a great dialogue with her
this show's really going for a lot of
that you know one person's terrorist is
another person's freedom fighter kind of
perspective but i did like how sam was
like dude
i get your fight i just don't agree with
how you're fighting it i mean
let's be real you bombed places you've
killed people i like the thought
experiment
of where the line is between oh this
this group's freedom fighter
this group's extremists though there's
one moment i don't think that's what
they were doing
i think this moment was just they were
like this will track well on twitter is
when the dora milaje
show up to take zemo they're like okay
eight hours is up we're taking him now
and john walker's like hello
captain mary you know he's like douching
it up and he brings up a point he's like
durham elijah don't have jurisdiction
here in which one of them responds the
dora melange have jurisdiction wherever
the dora melange find themselves to be
which made me be like wait a minute is
that
is that official wakanda policy huh
that seems pretty radical and extreme if
you mentally flip it that does
sound like something john walker would
say also just now realize he's named
after a [ __ ] alcohol i'm gonna call
him johnny walker
now there's no one doing that but yeah
johnny walker walks into a scene and
someone was like captain america has no
jurisdiction here i could imagine
him being like captain america has
jurisdiction wherever captain america
happens to find himself to be and we'd
all be like ooh
that's such a dick thing to say so i i
found that interesting
respect over the fact that they put a
failsafe in bucky's arm that they gave
him you just give bucky's arm the pain
five-point exploding heart technique and
his arm just
falls off like joey tribiani's fake dick
and friends
i gotta say i'd do the same thing anyone
would it's like ah
super soldier slash former hydra death
machine
we fixed you here's a new arm
yeah just all right we all know the
fail-safe case this dude snaps
in case we didn't fully fix them i mean
you gotta have a fail safe i thought
that was pretty smart
you can tell bucky's like really my arm
that's [ __ ] up still didn't look quite
as crushed just johnny walker losing his
fight on the playground and zemo shows
up man he starts stepping on those vials
like ants and you know you're like
there's gonna be one
there's gonna be one that he missed
there is one that he missed that
johnny walker's like yeah save this for
later
just in case just in case i lose a fight
on the playground
and at first i was kind of confused
because captain not america captain
douche
was just kicking dudes across rooms and
throwing the shield into a wall
i mean at first i was like oh he threw
the shield into the wall but
vibranium does that regardless it was
kind of neat to see him smashing through
doors throwing the shield into
a wall bending a pipe dude's like oh
[ __ ] kicks him across the room
does a superhero landing without even
getting a compound fracture it gets kind
of
it's one of those moments in here where
when his friend
i mean dies i assume he's dead i mean
he's
it's made to look like he's people live
through marvel [ __ ] all the time
half the universe was vaporized and came
back man i don't know vision's kind of
back
he's pretty much vision again only not
vision but he's vision anyhow
johnny walker goes into drunken rage
but he chases this dude down and just
beats him to death
and but beats him to death i mean beats
his ass and then takes the shield and
you're like oh here it is
the homelander moment and just crushes
the shield down on him
with a lot of cell phones recording in
which i feel like
johnny walker legitimately needs
homelanders pr person because
homelanders pr
person made everyone flip back onto the
homelanders side in season two
that's what this dude needs cause i
don't know if that'll be the way it goes
down in the mcu
savage imagery though with him holding
that shield in blood i was like
it was it was good it was good imagery
there is one part in this episode where
i was like
is that how that conversation would have
gone down it has to do with zemo's
perspective on super soldiers you know
in captain america civil war he was like
no more super soldiers and avengers they
just need to burn but in the
conversation about super soldier serum
and how it corrupts people and he's like
she's a super soldier she is
on the path to corruption already and
then the hypothesis or observations
thrown his way of well
it didn't corrupt steve rogers and he
was like true but there's never been
another steve rogers but i was like
what do you see it that way though i
feel like that compromises his
extremism you know his mindset because
he now has to humor the idea
that if it happened once then it could
happen again
if someone didn't get corrupted once
well then there could be another super
soldier out there who doesn't get
corrupted steve rogers is a
contradiction to his entire mindset
about super soldiers i feel like his
response would be like
would he not because he's still part of
the group that killed my family so yeah
you know you say he wasn't corrupted i
say it's a matter of perspective i feel
like that's how
might have gone down rather than him
being like yeah steve rogers
was awesome this is how i see it but
regardless zemo is still the element
that
elevated this show for me because the
way i see it the show should be called
zemo in his two tag alarms
zemo and his plus ones so like i said
solid episode a lot happened digging the
fact that the episodes are longer than
juan division though i did like the what
the [ __ ] is happening
intrigue that one division had and i
feel like that kept people coming back
more
like with falcon in the winter soldier
people were like hey you know it's
another marvel adventure but as long as
i keep zemo around
i think they're good all right so falcon
in the winter soldier episode four have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you